مع اقتراب دخول العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
في اوكرانيا عامها الثاني لم تحقق موسكو
اهدافها المعلنه للحرب فبحسب صحيفه
جارديان البريطانيه انتكاسات كبيره منيات
بها روسيا اولها ان تصور الرئيس الروسي
للعمليه الخاطفه كان خاطئا تحولت لحرب
مدمره لا تعرف نهايتها القوات الروسيه
فشلت في الاستيلاء على العاصمه وتحول
الصراع لحرب استنزاف تسببت بمقتل الالاف
كما يستبعد خبراء عسكريون شن روسيا لهجوم
جديد مهم مرجعين ذلك الى تدهور القدرات
الروسيه بسبب الحرب في المقابل اصبحت
اوكرانيا اقوى واكتسبت انظمه افضل
بالانظمه افضل وتحصل على المزيد من
الاسلحه اما احتمالات القتال شرقي
اوكرانيا فتشمل تكثيف روسيا لوتيره
هجماتها في باخموت خشيته هجوم الاوكراني
كبير او لاغراض دعائيه
[موسيقى]